[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Web Security
Scanner is a built-in service
for the Security Command
Center Premium tier.
It can automatically scan for
and detect key vulnerabilities
in App Engine, Compute Engine,
and Google Kubernetes Engine
applications before
deploying them to production.
There are two types
of scans you can do.
Managed scans are
configured and managed
by Security Command Center.
With an SCC Premium
subscription,
they're enabled by default
and will automatically run
once a week.
Results will appear in
the SCC Vulnerabilities
tab and related reports.
With managed scans,
you can centrally
manage basic web application
vulnerability detection
for projects in
your organization
without having to involve
individual project teams.
If you disable managed scans,
you can re-enable them.
For this, you need the
SCC and Security Center
Sources Admin IAM roles,
along with the SCC Premium
subscription.
Go to the Sources and
Services Settings page
and enable managed scans.
You may need to wait up to
24 hours for the application
to be detected and scanned.
Custom scans are also available.
They provide granular control
over how the scan runs,
including additional controls
like scanning from a static IP
or using IAP authentication.
Before you begin, make sure
the account you're logged into
has a project editor, the
organization administrator,
Security Center Admin, and
Security Center Sources Admin
IAM roles.
To enable custom scans,
make sure you've also
enabled Web Security Scanner
in the Settings page.
To set up a custom
scan, first make
sure your app is running
with the public URL and IPs.
Then head to the
Web Security Scanner
from the navigation bar.
Select a project in
the page that appears.
If you haven't enabled the Web
Security Scanner API before,
you will be prompted to
do so before continuing.
You are now in the Web
Security Scanner page.
This page allows you to
create, save, and run a scan.
Click New Scan to display
the new scan form.
Add in the URL of the
application you'd like to test.
You can select authentication
options, including
needing a Google
account to run the scan
or using Identity Aware Proxy.
IAP works by verifying
user identity and context
of the request to
determine if a user should
be allowed to access.
And for now, let's schedule
the scan to run weekly
and select the starting date.
You can choose to run scans from
a predefined set of source IP
addresses.
This gives the scanner access to
applications behind a firewall,
but might limit the
scope of the scan.
The Export box is
automatically checked.
It allows scan results to
be displayed on the Security
Command Center dashboard.
You can also specify the user
agent, which is a web client
software to be emulated
when scanning your app,
max scan speed, queries
per second, and risk level.
Because Web Security
Scanner populates
fields, pushes buttons, clicks
links, and other interaction,
low-impact scanning minimizes
requests with a potential
to modify data.
Click Save to create the scan.
The scan will be
queued, and then it
will be run at a future time.
It might take several
hours before the scan runs.
Click Run to schedule the scan.
The scan is placed in a queue,
and there might be a delay
before it runs.
It can take several minutes or
many hours to complete a run,
depending on the system
load and site complexity.
Web Security Scanner
will automatically
crawl your
application, following
all links within the scope
of your starting URLs
and attempts to exercise as
many user inputs and event
handlers as possible.
The scanner attempts to identify
common web vulnerabilities
on these pages, including
findings from categories
in the OWASP Top 10, like
cross-site scripting,
mixed content, and outdated or
insecure JavaScript libraries.
The scan will display a
results page when it completes,
such as the following if no
vulnerabilities were detected.
Click the scan name to go to
the scan's config page, where
you'll find more information
about the scan, its history,
and some controls for running,
editing, or deleting the scan.
You can see all
vulnerabilities found
by navigating to the
Vulnerabilities dashboard.
Filter by vulnerability
type, like OWASP.
In this case, we have
the highest number
of cross-site scripting
listings and the recommendation
provided.
You can click on a
finding to bring up
more information about it.
If we click on this
cross-site scripting error,
for instance, a pop-up
will display information
about the finding,
including information
like the resource
that was flagged,
how severe the flag is,
and the reproduction URL.
You can also share the
scan with your team.
You just completed a scan
using Web Security Scanner.
You can now set up and run
on-demand, immediate or
scheduled security scans
for your own application
from the Google Cloud Console.
[MUSIC PLAYING]